alright so the constants are really my
one of my most favorite things and go
believe it or not I learned so much
about the language when I started
studying constants and every time I
think about our constants work and how
they've implemented them it just it
always preached out it's really so I
always start our fight by saying that
when I'm talking about something that's
an implementation detail you need to be
very aware of that so the specification
that's fixed right so we're backwards
compatibility as relates to the spec as
relates to the standard library but the
implementation of things can change it
happens all the time but they've just
changed house tax work in the language
for 12 to 13 right so we were writing
code based around the implementation of
stacks a lot of our code will now be
broken as we move done and so some of
the things I'm going to be talking about
our implementation details and it's nice
to know the implementation details can
help you find bugs but we cannot be
writing code against them so constants
are not variables right when we declare
a constant in the language we're
declaring something that exists only at
compile time eventually every constant
that we use has to be converted to a
variable that's really interesting
primarily as you guys probably if it up
against it quite a bit go is a type-safe
language so everything we do whether
it's with our variables whether it's
math assignments comparing things you've
got to have like types on both sides of
those operations
the compiler and goes never going to
implicitly convert a variable for you at
all now if our constants were variables
they would have that same exact
restriction which would make the
language very difficult to use when
instead is you're going to see constants
give us that bridge to allow us to do
things that are very intuitive way with
values and yet we still have a very
typesafe language
I like to think that Constance have a
parallel type system and what's nice is
is when we have untyped constants and
our programs the compiler can perform
those implicit conversions that can't
happen with our variables and that's
where we get a lot of flexibility in the
language those constants give us the
flexibility to have implicit conversion
to work with values and work with them
intuitively so take a look at these two
constants that I've declared here
they're untyped keyword cost I've given
it a name and I've assigned it a value
now when we're dealing with untyped
constants it's really good to think
about constant it's not having it tight
it has a kind so these two constants the
first one has kind integer the second
one it's good to think of it as kind to
loading point when something just has a
kind then it can be converted implicitly
to a type the compiler sees the decimal
point on the second one and determines
that that's going to be a kind floating
point they all they're both numeric but
we can make the distinction that one's
an integer and one as a floating point
now anytime we go to now run this
program and display these values these
constants have to get converted to a
value a ver a value of some type and so
when I run this print F command I'm
really not displaying the value of a
constant of displaying the value that
that was converted from constant to now
a value of it of a known type but when i
run this we're going to be told that you
I is of type int and UF will be a type
floating-point the compiler will do that
implicit conversion for us
now here are two constants where I bound
the constant to type information now
this is really important I said the
constants have their own parallel kind
system what that means is from an
implementation detail constants are not
implemented the same way variables are
the fact our constants have much greater
precision built into them then our
variables do the specification
has so arbitrary precision in other
words when we think of constants we want
to think of them is being mathematically
exact so I can technically store an
integer value of any size you want to
type for the next three weeks from a
specification standpoint we can store
that number a floating point number we'd
like to think of that is mathematically
exactly now from a specification
standpoint this is all that it says it
doesn't say how things can be
implemented but integers have to have at
least 256 bits could there be a compiler
that uses more absolutely but this is a
from the specification of Carmen saving
the floating points the mantissa has to
be at least 256 bits we could also
floating-point do rational that right
the compiler could use do fractional
math to be exactly precise the idea here
is though that we're using so many bits
to represent these numbers that they are
in essence mathematically exact that
gives the compiler and constant
arithmetic and advantage over our types
because an integer is bound to how many
bits 64 right our floating points are I
to bleep 754 that bound to that
precision but our constants are not
bound to any precision that's the way we
need to think of that though obviously
at some point here there's in this case
at least 256 bits so like I said
Constance kind of have their own
parallel type system right the way an
integer or floating point of those
values are stored completely different
from the way they end up being stored
for our variables so when I see these
two named constant a type 2 constants
all the type is doing its its finding
that value to that precision
it's not storing it as a variable would
be stored it's still using the compilers
representation parameters 256 bits of
precision can still be there okay so
these are not variables they're still
constant but we've kind of handcuffed to
these constants there now bound to that
type information so I now have a
constant here of type in 64 it is so
constant it's not a variable but now
it's bound to the laws of putting an
intense it's also bound to the laws of
having like types on any operation that
we perform so it's really and cuffing
the constant that's the way I see it but
there are times and we're going to see
we're doing that is is good so here's a
constant that I've given a type to you
went eight and I'm trying to assign the
value 1000 this is going to give me a
compiler why because the constant is
bound to the type information at that
point is this a variable no it's no a
constant pet represented by the compiler
this constants are but we've handcuffed
it the compiler will not allow that to
happen
this gets really interesting when we
start looking at constants in math
because if I try to take two variables
if I take a variable of type int and I
take a variable of type floating-point
the compiler will not allow me to do
math across those I will have to convert
one value to be the light st. type but
look what's happening here on line 36
I'm declaring a variable right I've used
the keyword bar here just to make that
very clear that answer is going to be a
variable but its value is based on the
map between the literal value 3 and
literal values by the way our constants
and go so that three is up what I call
unnamed constant and times point 333
when we have constants that are not type
I like to think of them as kind so I've
made this up here too so as we talk I
want you to think in terms of kind so 3
is of kind it which means it can be
converted to any numeric type that is
compatible with it dot 333 is a kind and
screwed up my comment there's I'm sorry
kind float now we're doing math against
something that is kind in and something
that is kind flown so what is the result
of that map well there are rules for
kind promotion in the language in this
case float is going to be promoted over
int so this equation is going to create
a constant of kind float and then that
constant of kind float that literal
value gets converted to a value of type
int and the compiler can do that there's
an implicit conversion
going on by the compiler here because
we're working with kinds constants of a
kind and as we talked about the
precision at the constant level the
constants type system has so much
greater present precision that doing
this math has greater precision as well
but as soon as I try to in this case
it's a variable but again anytime I see
a print F or print line that constant is
not going to being displayed a
conversion to a value of some type is
what's being displayed so let's look at
this here and hopefully you guys can see
Olympic so here is a I can only select
so here is a constant that we're
declaring and if equals 1/3 point 0 so
what is the result of this constant this
constant is going to be of kind floating
point I didn't this is this constant is
a constant if not being bound to a tight
so 1/3 point 0 will be kind in / kind
float float gets promoted and so the
result will be that division is
precisely mathematical use items we want
to look at it and now constant is going
to be a constant third is going to be a
constant of kind flow
what's happening here i'm doing math
against two constants of kind int so 0
is going to be in what kind int which
means the value of the value of this
equation is going to be 0 there's
nothing there to turn it into a floating
point to get the exact representation of
153 so I have in this case a constant of
kind inch
and here's a case where declaring a
constant and I'm giving it specifically
this type information I'm saying this
constant is a type in tape as it's so
constant yes but I've handcuffed that
I've given it I found it to type I've
assigned it the value of one so this is
a constant that one is a constant right
it's a constant of kind it if the
compiler can implicitly convert that
value to a value of type and take really
a constant that's bound to intake now
look what I'm doing on the next line I'm
taking the literal value of two times 11
is it constant but I bound it to type in
28 anytime I'm dealing with type I have
to have light pipes on either side of
that operation so what does the compiler
do the compiler treats to now as an
intake if that literal value cannot be
represented as an eight we will get a
compiler error and so the result of this
math here too will end up being a
constant of type and a ok int this type
is going to get promoted at that point
so there's a type involved then we
didn't have kind promotion here we have
time for motion however constant to is
still what still constant so if i run
this program
and even though it's running every value
being displayed on the screen down here
ends up really not being the value that
the constant at it is the value of that
constant being converted to a value of
that particular type you guys see all
that this is this is cool stuff right
that untyped constant has a lot of
freedom i'm going to show you now an
implementation from the standard library
then when I was first learning go farm
astray this first and now i'm sure that
so how can I prove to you that constants
are mathematically exact when every time
I go to run a program constants have to
get converted to a value some type right
but our program is running a conflict
that can fire is gone so take a look at
this here are two constants the first
constant represents a number that is the
max integer value for 64-bit so that's
it look at bigger the constant bigger
how large is the number that I'm storing
in that constant I made a significant
larger than a 64-bit integer all right
so if the compiler is mathematically
exact and I try to compile this I should
not get a compiler and I won't i can run
this program right now clicks groups
what just happened there
there was a crime hmm
I lost the airplay here we go so I run
this it compiles and runs now if I
uncomment this line right here what am I
doing here with this content I'm binding
it to type information right the type
system that we use for ballys now if I
try to run this I'm going to have a
problem and it's not because the
constant itself can't store that number
this is still a constant it's because
I've bound the constant to only that
level of precision and it will respect I
wish I can do this for floating points
this is the only example I can come to
show you how these numbers are
mathematically exact we can store
numbers larger than what our value type
system can handle this really tripped me
up when I was first learning about go
because i was looking at constants as
being just read only variables sorry
so let's start with something here so
that is a named type in go I'm declaring
a type its name is duration and its base
type it's based on and int64 this comes
from this is how duration is actually
declared in the time package but let's
look at a few things here so they are
like 12 I'm declaring a variable called
duration of type duration I'm displaying
the value of duration on the screen
which will be the 0 value for that
variable so it should get zero and then
I'm declaring another variable here
called nano second i'm taking the
literal constant 10 converting it
specifically write explicitly to a value
of type in 64 so nanosecond is a
variable of type in 64 the same type as
duration is based items right but in go
far as the compiler is concerned if i
try to do this assignment I'm dealing
with variables of two different types it
doesn't matter that duration is a name
type that's based on n64 after that
declaration duration is duration its
representation underneath is the rough
these are not compatible variables there
are two different types and so if I try
to do this I'm going to get an error
that's very specific can I use a
nanosecond type in 64 as type duration
the compilers telling you do these are
apples and oranges not going to happen
all right in order to make anything like
that work I've got to explicitly
convert 90 seconds to a value of type
duration to be able to have light types
on that assignment so is the type safe
language you want to play you've gotta
play with light types at all times that
keeps everything nice and safe keeps you
out of trouble but you can see how
restrictive that is right we have to do
these conversions in order to be able to
take these values and use them in
different ways but the language
designers because of constants it's
brilliant they're going to give us back
all that flexibility they're going to
make the language really simple easy to
use thanks to Constance so this is
pulled right out of the time package
that's the type the name type duration
and here are constants that are declared
in the time package these are typed
constants alright the first constant
right here is of type duration it's set
to a value of one and then we're doing
constant arithmetic here right but that
value 1000 is going to be treated as a
value of what time duration because of
type promotion because this is all sort
of type duration which means that this
constant is going to be a void title
duration cool so I've got all of these
typed constants right there all of type
duration all right let's get to know and
then i have this function that we're
going to play with add an takes a value
of what type duration which we know has
a base
64 but duration is still duration and
n64 is still in 64 all right let's see
how this works so here's a constant that
I'm declaring let's going to use it you
some some multiplier here what is five
seconds after this well I'm taking the
literal value of five which is a kind
int a multiplying it by time dot second
which is a constant of type duration we
do that math and on five seconds is
going to be a value of type duration so
this is a type constant no problem so I
get now use the time package we get now
and look at this line right here and
takes a value of type duration what if I
pass it to that function a constant of
kind it I'm passing a constant of time
of kind in that means that the compiler
can do what for me that can convert it
to a value of type duration that is
compatible how cool is that same thing
on the next line line 45 5 seconds is a
constant of what time what constants of
time duration can be converted to values
of type duration that is also legal but
you see how the constant here on line 42
game is that flexibility
I didn't have to explicitly convert that
to duration because it's an untyped
constant because it's a kind int the
compiler can start banning them okay
I'll fix that for you no problem all
with the call go through well make it
happen because it's happening if the
compiler right the compiler can
guarantee the safety pneus of that
statement how cool is that the
flexibility we're getting from that
consonant so if i run this everything
will run now i'm in the playground and
then the playground time is always fixed
which is always fun when i try to do
things with time and I try to randomize
things on time and everyone works but
point of running this is that it compile
it was able to do those implicit
conversions because those constants were
of kind let's take a look at this next
one same thing we are named tight we
have our constants okay we've got our
add function I've created my five
seconds again or way I just look at this
one oops sorry now I did that when I was
running through this too okay here we go
I'm just doing doing some bad things
here I'm creating a variable here of
type in 64 by explicitly converting the
value minus five which is a kind integer
264 so minus five is a variable now I
try to pass that variable by Evan 64
through add you might think at first
well duration is a base type of the
region's and 64 so this should work but
it won't the compiler now is going to
say no don't have like types that is not
a constant of some kind that is a
variable that is already bound to fight
we've got to have white types and when
we look at the when we look at the error
that follows it's very clear okay the
type is not right so we're going to get
that error so the constants can be
implicitly converted but our variables
cannot even when we know the base type
is compatible all right
now I've done something a little
different on line 34 what have I done
I've handcuffed that constant it is no
longer going in this case well I've done
something even worse to it I'm not even
allowing the promotion of the math to
set the type of the constant right I'm
trying to say hey I want this constant
to be I'm 864 that can't happen because
promotion is going to make all of this
duration so I'm going to get a compiler
at the constant level it's going to tell
me very specifically I can't use this
little rally 5 as duration times another
value of type duration as n64 I really
love the compiler errors a chromatic go
if you really read then they're very
descriptive what is happening here and
first I used to scan through them for
now when i get a compiler don't really
know what's happening and you look at
that language and a lot of it came to me
from reading the spec over and over
again which was a chore for me but once
you learn the language in the spec and
you see these compiler errors coming
through they match very very clear it's
very rare an error comes out of a
compiler but doesn't it can't be found
at the spec level and you can understand
very cook quickly what's happening here
but I've created two problems in this
program
even though five seconds doesn't compile
the compiler still sees it as type in 64
because of the way I declare and here
now I'm trying to take a constant of
type in 64 and pass it through this
function is type duration the compiler
says again no you're not it's not going
to happen so when I went it with
constant and you can see the time
package is using a type constant right
very very effectively but when you start
looking at your programs and you might
get in these type errors and you're
working with constants look at that
constant this is a time constant or not
type constant do I need flexibility in
this constant and this is something that
I might want to use and I need these
values with literal values to be
converted to other types I need to use
an untied constant and let the compiler
do that work for me get the flexibility
in the language like to work with these
literal values on how we're doing
explicit conversion but the compiler do
that work there are times though as we
saw the time package where it's nice to
bind that constant why because when I'm
doing that mathematics I want the math
to be battled to the type that I'm
dealing with and if i'm working with
those constants right that duration the
duration value a lot of the functions in
time work with values of tidewater
duration so what I've also done is I
from an API standpoint I kind of
enforced that everybody has to be
working with duration right they've
created an API around the constant you
want to use that no problem we're only
going to take duration you want the
greatness of constants with all that
mathematical precision no problem all
right but if you want in this case I
have very specific values for each time
seconds milliseconds are all over
specific time but I'm now able to just
find that to a type and use
part of the API so this is why I love
Constance it was like we have this type
problem I'm not going to allow these
types to ever implicitly be converted
but like the programmer needs
flexibility will do it in constants will
create that parallel type system kind
system and now when they need the
flexibility they can have it and then
when that API or building needs to be
bound to something specific to make sure
that we're doing things right we can
find that constitute let's try to answer
them as best as i can tell you
absolutely can do math all that yeah so
he asked me what happens if I'm trying
to do multiplication of two integers
that are larger than n 64 the compiler
is going to do it we look at those
untyped constants as mathematically
exactly so you want to spend a week
typing in integers we have to consider
from the specification that that's going
to happen but what's the problem at some
point that constant the value that
console has to be converted to a value
of some type so at that point you're
going to have truncation you're going to
have a precision come up because we
can't work with constants forever
eventually our program has to run
you won't get an error sleep the
compiler is going to implicitly convert
that value to whatever that type is if
it can't fit is going to be truncation
remember as soon as I call print at that
constant a longer exists it has to be
converted to a value of a node type
which is why the only way I can show you
the constants are mathematically correct
is by declaring an untyped constant put
in a really large integer in and then is
to see if the compiler things I can't
display it's going to have to get tricky
you only have 64 bits for it too
if it fits inside that 64 bit young then
you're going to be fun writing yeah
any advice for static
past
well isn't that what kinda we just saw
at the time package they declared a
named tight right and that name type
became part of the API for all those
time function the seven can be
implicitly converted just like today if
I put five in that add function what am
I really passing passing the five
microseconds right there first constant
so and remember how many people tripped
up on that I did write a bunch of times
so so there's no way it was statically
set a statically typed set of inos but
what is the purpose to get for them six
let's let's talk after because it's for
much in won't resume yeah
right ask that question the rat I wasn't
sure I understood the question so like
fine
to find
Michael area I've not seen any
implementation that would support that I
haven't
assuming
those are type constants and that
Matthew star is all compile time at
runtime now we're talking about values
of that other type system
there's a package called big there's a
big math package all ready and go that
will give you the ability to work with
very large numbers and do rational map
as well so the support is there already
it's part of a standard library
I don't think so remember you have to
eventually your program has to run and
you have to work with values of that
type system the these untyped these
constants are a compiler level construct
giving us that flexibility to work with
literal values so they can be implicitly
converted make our code very easy and
clean to work with it would be a
nightmare if we had to explicitly
convert the number five let's say to
just some type that we're good